here's what happened in the Argentina
Netherlands World Cup quarterfinal the
Dutch were able to keep Argentina's
Lionel Messi quiet for a large part of
the half until the 35th minute that's
when Messi picked up the ball in the
Midfield he dribbled past several Dutch
Defenders and slotted a no-look pass to
Defender nahuel Molina who toe poked a
pass goalkeeper Andrew snowper Argentina
went up 1-0 and went into the half with
the lead the second half began with a
confident Argentina side turning up the
pressure on the Dutch defenders in the
71st minute Argentine Defender Marcos
Acuna won a penalty against Denzel
Dumfries Messi stepped up and scored it
Argentina took the lead 2-0 10 minutes
later six foot six inch tall Dutch
substitute vote veg horse headed across
into the back of Emiliano Martinez's
goal the Dutch got one back in the 88th
minute after a hard tackle on Defender
Nathan AKA Argentine Defender landro
Paredes kicked the ball into the Dutch
bench both teams clashed on the
touchline as the referee nearly lost
control only a yellow card for Paredes
in the 101st minute the Dutch got a free
kick outside the penalty area instead of
shooting on goal substitute Towing Coupe
miners slid an unexpected pass through
to veg horse right in front of the goal
and he shot it into the back of the net
full time ended 2-2 but tensions flared
as Argentine players and coaches voiced
frustration at the referee referee Mateo
lahos issued multiple yellow cards
during the break in extra time Argentina
picked up the intensity but still none
of their shots could find the back of
the net after 120 Minutes the score
remained tied the teams headed to
penalties the first two Dutch tries were
blocked by goalkeeper Emiliano Martinez
Lionel Messi was first up for Argentina
and scored and Leandro Paredes later
found the net making it 2-0 for
Argentina next Coupe miners finally
scored one for the Dutch it was 2-1 both
teams scored their next penalties making
it 3-2 Enzo Fernandez could have won it
for Argentina but missed then Luke De
Young kept the Dutch Alive by making it
3-3 but latero Martinez scored next and
sealed the victory for Argentina
the match ended with a record-breaking
17 total yellow cards Argentina heads to
the semi-final where they'll face
Croatia on December 13th
[Applause]